summer movies are already breaking
box-office records in the US
blockbusters help bring in more than one
point two billion dollars in ticket
sales in June
that's 19 percent higher than in June
last year highly anticipated movies like
marvels ant-man and the wasp Mission
Impossible fall out and crazy rich
Asians will hit theaters in July and
August it's a title I never thought I'd
see Eric Davis is managing editor at
Fandango welcome welcome Eric all right
let's start let's start with Mission
Impossible fall out which is the sixth
movie in the franchise and and what do
we expect here I love these movies you
know Tom cruisers know one of Tom
Cruise's status who literally risks his
life to make these movies to give the
audience something they never seen
before on a big screen for this movie
this guy jumped out of a plane a hundred
times
to take this 3-minute skydiving sequence
got his helicopters pilot's license just
so he could be the one flying the
helicopter for a wild chase sequence you
know they deliver everything the thrills
the chills the humor it's got a nice
ensemble cast there's a mystery to it
these movies in my opinion are the
perfect summer movies and cruise he
knows how to deliver I agree I have a
theory that every movie that he's in
he's required to run in these movies
especially the Mission Impossible we're
up to so many now and yet they continue
to bring in huge numbers yeah they were
just very well done and director
Christopher McQuarrie who is on this one
he's the first one to do two
back-to-back Mission Impossible Blues I
think he's a really talented guy and
they cook up some good stories my father
always told me growing up Tom Cruise is
a guy that gives you your money's worth
[Laughter]
okay speaking of parents my mother every
summer is like Alex you need to read
crazy rich Asians she loves this book my
mother is a a crazy wonderful Asian and
this is an all Asian cast yes sort of
the Wakanda for my Asia fellow Asian
brethren tell us about it the Hollywood
I think The Hollywood Reporter calls it
one of one of the most interesting films
I think it could be the sleeper hit of
this summer you know it's got these lush
lavish production values its colorful
visually stunning you know it's me it's
got a lot of music to it it's a musical
but it's not a musical it reminds me in
that way of like a dirty dancing know
how dirty dancing is the kind of film
where you've seen it a thousand times
every time it's on cable you can't not
watch it yeah I think crazy rich Asians
is going to be that film for a lot of
people the title is yeah and the
trailers intriguing as well mm-hmm Spike
Lee has a new film black clansmen which
The Hollywood Reporter calls his most
flat-out entertaining film and quite
sometimes yeah a lot of critics say this
is Spike's most entertaining film in a
long time
you know most fascinating thing about
this it's based on a real story an
absurd story of this black cop in the
early 70s who infiltrated the Ku Klux
Klan she went undercover makes no sense
John David Washington Denzel Washington
son plays him in this movie his name is
Ron Stallworth he teams up with a white
cop Adam driver who is the physical
embodiment of this character that they
create and they actually thwart some
like some pretty heavy acts of violence
that are being planned by the Klan it's
good it's very funny it's got that
absurdist humor to it but of course it's
Spike Lee so it's going to draw some
parallels to today's times sure over
over the weekend I saw Incredibles 2
with my six-year-old who hadn't seen
Incredibles 1 yet and it's quite amazing
to see first of all from the production
and technology standpoint what they got
done in the past 16 or 17 years oh yeah
but but this Incredibles 2 could be the
biggest blockbuster summer movie right
oh yeah no I mean it would definitely
had the biggest opening of any animated
movie that we've ever seen and it's
fantastic and it's got a lot of
parenting humor I've watched this movie
I can't do my kids math homework and
there is a math is math in this one and
I related to it incredibly and it's an
incredible movie there they are not
going to wait 14 years let's put that
way before they make a third incredible
yeah yeah
Eric ant-man and the wasp before we go
what do we need to know I love it you
know the ant-man is Marvel Studios most
family-friendly franchise I have a lot
of parents on my block who didn't take
their kids to see infinity war a black
panther because they were a little bit
more intense this one you can bring the
whole family to its light it's breezy
it's got a fun story Evangeline Lilly
the first female character first female
superhero in the title of a Marvel
Studios movie and she steals the show
she makes it worth going opens this
weekend you can't go to a beach go to a
movie exactly good choice up corn
air conditioning Eric Davis thank you so
much happy fourth